en este vídeo veremos el mecanismo sn
uno y empezaremos con nuestro alumno de
alquilo o también llamado halogenuro de
alquilo entonces en el primer paso de
nuestro mecanismo s en eeuu no perdemos
al grupo saliente así que los electrones
en este enlace se van junto con el bromo
para formar el ión bromuro y cuando eso
ocurre le quitamos un enlace a este
carbono de color rojo ahora el carbono
en rojo tiene una carga formal positiva
vamos a dibujarlo ok y el carbono rojo
corresponde a este carbón y ahora tiene
una carga formal positiva tenemos un
kart vocación miren el carbono rojo pasó
de tener una hibridación sp3 en el
alumno de alquilo a una hibridación sp2
en nuestro carbó catión eso significa
que la geometría alrededor del carbono
rojo es plana y también tenemos el
bromuro vamos a dibujarlo por acá
que tiene cuatro pares de electrones
libres a su alrededor
lo que le da una carga formal negativa
ese es el yom bromuro entonces los
electrones en este enlace se fueron con
el bromo para formar el ión bromuro que
es un buen grupo saliente así que en el
primer paso de nuestro mecanismo s en
eeuu no perdemos al grupo saliente y
cuando eso ocurre se forma el carb
ocasión nuestro carbó catión tiene una
carga formal positiva en este carbono
así que funcionará como nuestro electro
filo mientras que nuestro núcleo filo
será el ión hidrógeno sulfuro que tiene
una carga negativa
recuerden cargas opuestas se atraen así
que en el segundo paso de nuestro
mecanismo nuestro núcleo filo ataca al
electro filo entonces en el segundo paso
ocurre el ataque núcleo físico
ataque
el núcleo físico y un par de electrones
libres en el azufre forma un enlace con
el carbono de color rojo entonces en
nuestro producto final
este es nuestro carbono rojo y si
resaltamos el par de electrones libres
del azufre ese par de electrones libres
formó este enlace en nuestro producto
ahora les quiero mostrar un vídeo de
este mecanismo usando un modelo
molecular
estos son los saludos de alquilo y la
esfera verde es el bromo entonces en el
primer paso de nuestro mecanismo nos
deshacemos del grupo saliente así que
estos electrones se van junto con el
bromo para formar el ión bromuro y así
formamos un kart vocación pero al usar
este modelo molecular no parece que
todos los carbonos estén en el mismo
plano así que les tengo otro modelo
molecular para que puedan ver que todos
los carbonos si están en el mismo plano
porque el carbono del centro tiene una
hibridación sp2
si vemos el kart vocación desde arriba
podemos ver el dibujo verdad así es como
lo dibujamos en nuestro mecanismo y
ahora el núcleo filo entra que es helio
nitrógeno sulfuro y el núcleo filo puede
atacar ya sea por arriba o por abajo
porque tenemos un carbó catión plano y
de cualquier forma obtendremos el mismo
producto que lo tenemos aquí aquí
regresamos a un carbono con hibridación
sp3 así que en el producto final tenemos
una geometría te trae drica el primer
paso en nuestro mecanismo que es la
pérdida del grupo saliente resulta ser
el paso más lento y el segundo paso es
decir el ataque núcleo físico es el paso
rápido y este mecanismo es consistente
con la velocidad de reacción determinada
experimentalmente la velocidad de la
reacción es igual a la constante de
velocidad k por la concentración de
nuestro alumno de al kilo entonces por
los experimentos se ha determinado que
esta es la ley de veloz
y es igual a la concentración de nuestro
alumno de alquilo elevada a la primera
potencia entonces la velocidad de
reacción depende de la concentración del
alumno de alquilo pero no de la
concentración del núcleo filo y eso es
porque el primer paso es el paso lento
este es el paso determinante de la
reacción y si se acuerdan de esto en
química general eso significa que si
incrementamos la concentración de
nuestro alumno de alquilo por un factor
de 2 también aumentamos la velocidad por
un factor de 2 ya que es una reacción de
primer orden con respecto al alumno de
alquilo pero si tratamos de incrementar
la concentración del núcleo filo
supongamos que incrementamos la
concentración del núcleo filo por un
factor de 2 esto no tiene ningún efecto
en la velocidad porque es de orden 0 con
respecto al núcleo filo el núcleo filón
no puede atacar hasta que se forme el
carbó catión y eso depende únicamente de
la
centra ción de la luro de alquilo por
eso es que esta reacción
este primer orden con respecto a nuestro
alumno de alquilo entonces esta es una
reacción s n 1 s por sustitución
sustitución n por núcleo física y uno se
refiere a que esta es una reacción un y
molecular un y molecular y eso significa
que la velocidad de la reacción depende
de la concentración de una sola cosa que
en este caso es nuestro sustrato es
decir el allure o de alquilo entonces
esta es una reacción de primer orden con
respecto a la luz de alquilo y
sustitución núcleo física quiere decir
que en nuestro producto el núcleo filo
ha sido sustituido por el grupo saliente
ese es un mecanismo sn uno la estructura
del sustrato también afecta a la
velocidad de reacción por ejemplo si
empezamos con un alumno de alquilo
terciario como el que teníamos en el
ejemplo anterior obtendremos un kart
vocación terciario entonces estos
electrones se van junto con el bromo y
nos quedamos con un kart boca t un
terciario aquí tenemos una carga formal
positiva y sabe
que los carbó cationes terciarios son
los más estables vimos eso en un vídeo
anterior entre más grupos al kilo
tengamos más densidad electrónica
podemos donar para ayudar a estabilizar
esta carga positiva ahora si empezamos
con una luro de alquilo secundario
cuando estos electrones se van con el
bromo nos quedamos con un carbó catión
secundario ahí está y un kart vocación
secundario únicamente es estabilizado
por dos grupos al kilo que en este caso
serían estos dos grupos metilo y como un
kart vocación secundario no es tan
estable como uno terciario un kart
vocación terciario se formará mucho más
rápido así que los saludos de alquilo
terciarios son más reactivos en un
mecanismo sn 1 mientras que un alumno de
alquilo primario y un alero de metilo no
tienen un kart vocación tan estable
incluso el carb ocasión es muy inestable
para existir por lo que generalmente un
alumno del kilo
y no reacciona mediante un mecanismo sn
1 y lo mismo ocurre con el allure o de
metilo ahora en el ejemplo anterior
teníamos un núcleo filo con una carga
formal negativa pero qué hacemos si
nuestro núcleo filo es neutro en este
caso el oxígeno de la molécula de agua
no tiene carga pero todavía puede actuar
como núcleo filo en el mecanismo sn 1
así que nuestro primer paso es la
pérdida del grupo saliente entonces
estos electrones se van con el cloro
para formar el a neón cloruro y como le
quitamos un enlace a este carbono de
color rojo
entonces ese carbono tendrá una carga
formal positiva y si dibujamos nuestro
carbó catión tratando de mostrar la
geometría plana alrededor del carbono
central que tiene una carga formal
positiva en el siguiente paso sabemos
que el núcleo filo ataca al electro filo
entonces nuestro núcleo filo tiene este
oxígeno con una carga
la negativa verdad porque el oxígeno es
más electro negativo que estos
hidrógenos así que retira un poco de
densidad electrónica y un par de
electrones libres en el oxígeno pueden
formar un enlace con este carbono así es
como nuestro núcleo filo ataca al
electro filo y ahora dibujemos lo que se
forma aquí tenemos estos grupos y
después tenemos el oxígeno que ahora
está unido al carbono y también sigue
unido a dos hidrógenos entonces déjenme
resaltar los electrones de color rosa
estos electrones forman un enlace entre
el oxígeno y nuestro carbono que serían
estos electrones y aún tenemos un par de
electrones libres en el oxígeno vamos a
dibujarlos así que ahora el oxígeno
tiene una carga formal positiva entonces
si comparamos este intermediario con
nuestro producto final observen que
únicamente nos falta deshacernos de
protón mediante una reacción ha sido
base entonces otra molécula de agua
puede actuar como una base y esta
molécula puede tomar uno de estos
protones por ejemplo puede tomar este
dejando estos electrones en el oxígeno
vamos a resaltar esos electrones de
color rojo estos electrones en rojo
terminan en el oxígeno con lo que
nuestro producto final es neutro es
decir no tiene carga y así es como se
forma el ter butano esta es una reacción
conocida como sol bo lisis lo escribiré
esta es una reacción de sol policies
significa que el solvente es el núcleo
filo y en este caso nuestro solvente es
el agua que también funciona como un
núcleo filo en este mecanismo